can you measure happiness it's not an
easy task but every year the Gallup
World poll tries to estimate how happy
people are in a hundred and forty
countries around the world where do they
even start frequency of smiley face
emojis number of hugs given per day we
actually start by asking a few simple
questions first researchers ask people
to rate their lives on a scale of zero
to ten zero being the pits and ten being
the happiest possible if you rate your
lives on a seven or higher you're
considered to be driving way to go what
stands out when you dig deeper into
these poll results one thing is clear
different cultures have different ideas
of what it means to thrive
for example latin americans tend to
place an especially high value on
positive emotions including laughter and
consistently score highest in the daily
positive experiences so it's no surprise
that in Costa Rica healthy and green
living means happiness investments in
health care education sustainability and
biodiversity have helped Costa Ricans
flourish the beautiful natural landscape
also leads to a limited stress lifestyle
across the pond
Dane's ranked among the happiest
countries in the poll believe they have
a right to health care education and a
financial safety net at least half of
Danes are thriving when it comes to
financial well-being and community
engagement meanwhile Singapore is rooted
in traditional Asian values of harmony
respect and hard work that's why over
the last decade it has led Southeast
Asia
and Happiness and overall satisfaction
with life so how can we increase
happiness
well the Dina just isn't there yet more
research is needed to truly understand
what makes people feel good across
cultures we know that physical health
and vitality are the most important
metrics for well-being but in the short
term a good place to start is
find happiness in everyday life go to a
park with a friend play with a puppy
find a hobby mostly just stay healthy
and discover what's important to you so
how do you measure happiness and what
makes you happy
[Music]
you